يقال الصمت سيد الكلام وهيبه العظماء وهو
كالدواء ان قللت منه نفع وان اكثرت منه
قتل هذا ما اثبتته نتائج دراسه علميه
حديثه خلصت الى ان الصمت من الذهب يقوي
موقف الموظف في طرح الافكار والاعراب عن
المخاوف الدراسه اجرتها كليه اداره
الاعمال في جامعه ماريلاند واوضحت ان
الموظفين الذين يحجبون عمدا اراءهم
ومخاوفهم الى حين اجراء تقييم شامل عليها
يلقون قبولا اكثر واذانا صاغيه من قبل
مدرائهم تتحدى دراسها الراي السائل
للخبراء بان الصمت في العمل دارون بطبيعته
وتشير لان الموظفين الاعلى اداء ينخرطون
في صمت استراتيجي عندما يعتقدون الفائده
من الكلام
الدراسه التي اجرتها كليه اداره الاعمال
في جامعه ميريلاند خلصت الى ان الموظفين
الاعلى اداء يحجبون عمدا معلوماتهم
وافكارهم حتى مخاوفهم وحتى يحين الوقت
المناسب للحديث عنها بحسب الدراسه فان
الموظفين الذين يستخدمون الصمت
الاستراتيجي ياخذون في عين الاعتبار ثلاثه
عوامل في تحديد متى وكيف يتحدثون اولا
يحددون ما اذا كان التحدث يتوافق مع اهداف
المتلقي ويلائم الوضع الحالي ثانيا يحددون
ما اذا كانوا مستعدين للتحدث او هم بحاجه
الى الانتظار حتى جمع المزيد من البيانات
المقنعه وايجاد حلول اكثر اقناعا ثالثا
ينتظرون حتى يكون المتلقي في حالته
المعرفيه الصحيحه ليس مشغولا وليس في مزاج
سيء ليكون اكثر سماعا واكثر استجابه وتخلص
الدراسه انه غالبا ما يكافئ الموظف الصامت
من قبل المدراء الذين ينظرون الى صوته على
انه اكثر قيمه للشركه والمهمه المطروحه
على كل حال سالنا الناس من الاقوى تاثيرا
في العمل الموظف الصامت ام الموظف المتحدث
[موسيقى]
الموظف المتكلم يبقى افضل المتكلم ده هو
اللي بيعرف ينقض المكان
سلبيات معظم مشاكلنا من شخص الصامت
الشخصيه وتاثيره على ممكن ينصح اللي قدامه
ممكن يقول له حاجات صح يوتيوب في شغله وفي
عمله وفي نفس الوقت لكن الصامت انا هستفيد
منه ايه على حسب برضو بيتكلم في ايه فاهم
ممكن تكون دي شخصيته مع ذلك برده هيطلع
شغله كويس وهيشتغل كويس بس هو شخصيته ان
هو متكلم صامت في الحياه لا ما بينفعش
المتكلم في الحقيقه دلوقتي هو اللي بينفع
كل واحد هيبقى له تاثير بطريقه معينه
تاثير في حته والمتكلم هيبقى له تاثير في
حته ده هيعرف يقصر بطريقه وده يعرف يقصر
بطريقه وهي دي الشطاره بقى حتى قالوا في
زمان يعني اللي هو الكلام من فضه فصامته
من ذهب يعني
[موسيقى]
على كلن ينضم الينا من رياض طراد تطوير
الذات طراد اهلا بك من يحقق اهدافه
بفعاليه اكبر الموظف الصامت استراتيجيا ام
الموظف المتكلم
من يحقق اهدافه هو من يعرف متى يتكلم
دائما يعني عندنا امثله رائعه لخصناها
ثلاثه في ثلاثه ثلاثه في الجانب العملي
ثلاثه في الجانب الاجتماعي وثلاثه في
الجانب الشخصي ندخل مباشره في الجانب
الشخصي في البدايه عشان تتضح الصوره رشا
ونادين وسهام رشاش ما شاء الله البصريه
اللي ممكن يدخل النقاش معاها زي ما لما
دخل الموضوع في محمد صلاح على الهواء تحت
الهواء وكملت نقاش مع نادين وبتناقش يعني
لازم تثبت صفحتها نادين سمعيه سمعين هذول
اكثر ناس مفضوحين على طول يعطيك ابنه لما
تتكلمي معاه ونادين تحب تثني وتحب تتحابر
وما عندها مشكله في ابداء رايها اثنت على
محمد قبل شويه وقالت له حلو عليك وتحب
تسمع الثناء سهام الانسانه الحسيه اللي ما
تحب تدخل في جدالات اخر تقرير لاربع ايام
عمل في الاسبوع
كانت يعني هي مع انه تكون في اربع ايام
هي كان نفسها تقول ليش راتبي اذا زادت
انتاجيه الشركه 86% يخفضوا رواتبنا ليش
بتزيد الانتاجيه بس فضلت الصمت عشان تدخل
في جدار وحوارات هذه الشخصيات في جانب
اجتماعي الجانب الاجتماعي اللي في ناس
يتجنبوا الخوض في المساواه بين الرجل في
عالمنا العربي يتجنب في المذاهب والاديان
يتجنبوا الحديث في الجنس فاحيانا تلاقيهم
صامتين في الجانب العملي يسموها زي ما
ظهرت في التقرير
ريدينا تايمن يعني هذا الموضوع انا لي صله
فيه بيتكلموا عن موضوع مفتخصصي موضوع
مبيعات موضوع تسويق موضوع ما حتيجي تسالني
وادخل انا اتفلسف واقول حاجه بعدين يطلع
شكلي غلط الحاجه الثانيه يعني يكون عندي
وقت اجمع معلومات لما تيجي تسالني عن شيء
وانا ما عندي عنه معلومه اترك لي مجال
اروح ابحث عنه والتايمنج لما المدير مثلا
يكون زعلان ولا تكون في حاله وفاه احتفال
بالضبط التوقيت جدا جدا
اول شغله يعني انا بحيي تشخيصك لشخصياتنا
فعلا يعني في الصميم هذا اولا وبحيي كمان
متابعتك لادق التفاصيل في برنامج صباح
العربيه كمان شكرا وثالث امر
ثالث امر انه اليوم في ما يتعلق بالموظف
الصامت والموظف المتحدث ايهما يفضل
المدراء ورؤساء الاعمال اكثر ماذا يفضلون
هل يفضلون موظف الصامت ولا الموظف الذي
يتحدث ويعبر عن نفسه
الاجابه والمثال الاجابه هو من يتحدث
ليكون لكلامه قيمه انا ابغى اسمع منك شيء
اقوله واو اضفت الي خليني احاول احول
كلماتك هذه الى عمل الى منتج من سواها
كارلوس غصن في نيسان المجتمع الياباني
مجتمع محافظ وخجول فكان يبغى منهم يشاركوا
يتكلموا يا جماعه اعطونا افكار فطلع لهم
قرار انه شهريا كل موظف لازم يطلع فكره
ولو ما طلع فكره تعتبر في تقييم الاداء
فبداوا الموظفين يتحدثوا يعني عندي القبور
هي اكبر منطقه فيها كنوز افكار في العالم
تسلماته وعنده افكار كانت ممكن تشغل
الكهرباء للمدن بدون توصيلات وبدون اشياء
وبدون اسلاك فالفكره منها انه لما فتح هذه
الفكره للناس قال لهم يتكلموا نيسان
ابتكرت اول محرك من الالمنيوم خفف الوزن
السياره خفف استهلاك الوقود سوى انجاز
كبير جدا فهو فعليا الشخص يقدر اذا تحدث
يعني انا كلمه اللي قلتها في الاجتماع
رايي اللي اعطيته في الصميم جاءت كلمه
واضحه عدلت نتيجه تركت اثر سوت ارتفاع في
المبيعات ازادت السعاده في في وجود الناس
وفي المحيط اللي في المكان هذه فعليا
الكلمه اللي ممكن تفرق املي كل شوي جالس
يتكلم لمجرد انه انا موجود ويدخل يفتي
يقول كلام تلاقي احيانا يقول لك اصمت قبل
ان يطلب منك السكوت فيعني لا تحط نفسك في
موقف نقول لك شكرا خلصنا يعني نتناقش بوقت
اخر شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض طراد تطوير
الذات شكرا جزيلا